[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce numéro du 7
8 litres d'eau ensemble nous ferons le
tour de l'actualité de la semaine dans
les yvelines
le sommaire de ce vendredi 11 octobre
vingt-huit mille élèves ont bénéficié du
plan de déploiement numérique scolaires
lancée par le département des yvelines
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et l'académie de versailles
l'officialisation du projet elle de ce
vendredi 9 octobre france veut tu encore
de thé paysans c'est la question que
posent les agriculteurs en colère les
conditions d'exercice de plus en plus
difficile une sensation d'agri bashing
avec les mesures anti pesticides
nous reviendrons sur ces problématiques
avec un éleveur rives inra déjà dans une
pratique sans produits chimiques
le vélodrome deuil national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines parmi les
zones test pour la 5g un troisième salon
hit only aux mureaux et une découverte
du monde de la bulle au travers d'un
atelier bd avant l'ouverture du festival
de la bande dessinée de buc
retour sur ce qui a marqué la semaine
dont le département
[Musique]
le lancement ce vendredi du plan de
déploiement numérique scolaire à saint
quentin en yvelines
ce projet s'inscrit dans le cadre de
contrats yvelines territoire de
l'agglomération
les deux sens quatre écoles élémentaires
et maternelles saint-quentinoise vont
pouvoir bénéficier de tablettes des
espaces numériques de travail ou encore
les solutions de projection interactive
le département a contribué à ce projet à
hauteur de plus de 3,7 millions d'euros
ce qui représente la moitié du montant
total
jean michel fourgous et pierre bédier au
micro d'aurélie rose le monde a changé
l'école doit changer le monde du travail
vous passer quasiment 80 % de votre
temps avec des outils numériques bien
sûr que on doit adapter l'école à cette
évolution des techniques c'est une
révolution par la démocratisation de
l'enseignement parce que bah ça permet à
tous les milieux à tous les enfants
quels que soient leurs origines quelles
que soient leurs niveaux de pouvoir être
mis à égalité
un partenariat a confirmé la cité des
métiers et l' agence nationale pour la
formation professionnelle des adultes
ont signé ce vendredi une convention
l'afpa aura dorénavant des permanences
hebdomadaires pour recevoir du public
dans l'établissement saint quentinois la
cité des métiers qui accueille environ
500 personnes par mois sera aussi
présente lors des événements de l'
agence nationale le président de la cité
des métiers et le directeur de l'afpa au
micro de mélanie poké le public que l'on
reçoit c'est un public essentiellement
de salariés qui cherche à rebondir sur
son métier a changé de filière
puisqu'aujourd'hui on sait que
on changera de métier trois ou quatre
fois dans sa vie et donc pour ce fait on
a besoin d'avoir des accompagnants des
partenaires qui nous soit fidèle au sein
de la cité des métiers au niveau des
demandeurs d'emploi des salariés qui
veulent se reconvertir mais aussi au
niveau des entreprises
car la promotion de la cité auprès des
entreprises et ainsi répondre aux
besoins en compétences des entreprises
il ya un gros besoin aujourd'hui de
recrutement au niveau des entreprises
élèves de primaires collégiens lycéens
mais aussi adultes tester votre niveau
d'orthographe samedi se déroule une
dictée pour tous au château de
versailles
ce championnat de dicter géante en
possède 237 à son compteur samedi elle
sera lue par l'animatrice maitena
biraben et l'humoriste gad elmaleh sa
dictée pour tous est organisé par
l'association force des mixités et
l'association nouvelles du vivre
ensemble
le thème la citoyenneté plus de 1000
jeunes sont attendus dans la demeure du
roi soleil
annick bouquay présidente de
l'association nouvelle de vivre ensemble
ou donnent des indications au micro de
manon par aldo et aurélie roses rouges
on va donner une autre image de la
dictée une autre image que moi-même
enfants juste quelque chose que je
détestais comme je prends beaucoup de
d'élèves mais je pense que là on le fait
de façon ludique
donc c'est une façon de s'approprier la
dictée de façon amusante dans un cadre
magnifique et puis ça sauf s'approprier
les mots s'approprier les phrases non
veut sensibiliser voilà au lieu que ces
beaux lieux culturels à cette histoire
qui est commune à tous et puis cette
langue propre à tout le monde et qui est
magnifique
l'ancien centre de tri de la poste de
mes voisins le bretonneux deviendra un
ensemble résidentiel de 18 logements
jeudi 10 octobre les représentants
d'horizon asset management l agence des
yvelines de c2c cdc habitat ont posé la
première pierre de cette résidence coeur
bérénice plus de 1200 m² dont les
travaux commenceront courant octobre
pour une livraison prévue 1er trimestre
2011 21 ces appartements sont cédés aux
bailleurs cdc grand paris habitat les
douze autres sont destinés à l'accession
à la propriété 70% d'entre eux ont déjà
été réservées le premier prix commencent
à 226 milles euros l'appartement
on écoute arnaud monney au micro de
mathilde de dominer la problématique du
logement c'est d'abord une problématique
de localisation et donc de rechercher
des actifs qui
permettre de créer du logement sans
augmenter l'artificialisation des sols
et en re densifiant les centres villes
donc forcément dès qu'on se situe au
niveau d'un bureau de poste
on sait qu'on a à peu près tous ses
atouts en main pour pouvoir construire
une opération intelligente et surtout
répondant à un besoin des populations
[Musique]
les agriculteurs étaient mobilisés mardi
pour bloquer plusieurs grands axes
routiers dans les yvelines un slogan
affiché france veut tu encore de thé
paysans pour dénoncer leur mal être
plusieurs points de blocage dont une
douzaine de tracteurs au péage de
saint-arnoult ils répondaient à l'appel
du syndicat fnsea et des jeunes
agriculteurs
mathilde et demi a rencontré l'un
d'entre eux aujourd'hui en fait on est
venus en tracteurs pour bloquer le péage
de saint-arnoult donc c'est plus une
action de coup de force que
que d'embêter réellement la population
ce qu'on fait ça de 11h à 14h et en fait
c'est exactement ça c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on veut nous imposer des bandes qui sont
pas cultivés enfin non cultivées au bord
des habitations
si on utilise vraiment des produits qui
sont dangereux très bien qu'ils ont
connue on les enlève ans déjà on utilise
dix fois moins de produits dangereux qui
a 10 ans et et à côté de ça on importe
des produits qui est du brésil le brésil
a autorisé 50 nouvelles substances
chimiques au genou en juin mais personne
ne dit rien on est tout le monde est
content de manger ses produits
dégueulasse qui arrivent de l'étranger
et nous on n'arrive pas à vendre nos
produits
voilà qui sont sains aujourd'hui donc
c'est pour ça qu'on fait un coup de
force aujourd'hui c'est un coup de force
national tous les autoroutes normalement
de montpellier jusqu'à ville sont
bloquées donc j'espère que l'état va
nous entendre et qu'on aura un nouveau
message alors on l'a entendu leur
principale revendication porte sur
l'épandage des pesticides à partir du
1er janvier 2020 la loi instaure des
mesures de protection comprenant des
zones de non traitement entre 5 et 10
mètres des habitations voisines des
terres cultivées cette demande est basée
sur les préconisations scientifique de
l'agencé nationale de sécurité sanitaire
pour les agriculteurs cela représente un
manque à gagner important et la mesure
est jugée trop rapide
eric sanson vous êtes avec nous vous
êtes agriculteur a offert jce bonjour
bonsoir vous êtes déjà dans une
agriculture dite moderne et sans
pesticides donc vous n'avez pas
participé à ces mots de près cette
mobilisation est ce que vous comprenez
vos confrères je les comprends tout à
fait c'est pas c'est pas facile de
lutter contre des pays qui ne qui n'ont
pas les mêmes règles que nous quand on
voit qu arrive du canada de la viande
qui est essentiellement élevé en fille
lotte ou quand arrive
le colza canadien qui est un colza ogm
qui va venir concurrencer notre colza
ils ont pas les îles ont pas les mêmes
règles
ils n'ont pas la même fiscalité non plus
en france on sait que le coût du travail
est très important donc effectivement il
se retrouve avec une concurrence qui est
déloyale quand on est même au travers de
l'europe face à des pays comme les pays
de l'est où la main d'oeuvre coûte très
peu d'argent
voilà on part on part avec avec un
handicap
après
je comprends aussi les populations
aujourd'hui qui veulent se prémunir des
risques sanitaires enfin des risques de
deux perturbateurs endocriniens ou de
produits polluants qu'on sait plus ou
moins cancérigènes donc il faut arriver
à allier deux je pense faut surtout
donner une possibilité aux agriculteurs
aujourd'hui et d'une nouvelle vision pas
de cette vision hérité des années 50 où
il fallait produire à tout prix à tous
crins sur des sols qui n'avaient jamais
été traités dont qui répondait très bien
aujourd'hui des sols ils ont subit quand
même des années des années d un
traitement
les matériaux sont de plus en plus
lourds on rentre dans les dents des
champs avec des tracteurs de plus en
plus lourd
on écrase la terre on démolit
malheureusement la vie souterraine
et quand on sait qu'un terrain qui n'est
pas traité qui est qui vit de façon
naturelle qui vit le vivant du sol on
retrouve jusqu'à 900 trous de ver de
terre au mètre carré des vers de terre
qui descendent à deux mètres cinquante
voire trois mètres de profondeur
donc quand arrive quand arrive la pluie
ils permettent à l'eau de s'infiltrer
jusqu'aux nappes phréatiques et puis a
contrario quand on a des périodes de
sécheresse très importante et bien par
capillarité l'eau va remonter va nourrir
la plante qui elle même par les tours et
réussi à descendre ses racines dans la
terre on va redonner la vie à la prairie
la prairie c'est hydro régulateur ça
évite les inondations l'hiver et puis ça
permet de nourrir toute une faune tout
une flore on peut refaire du miel on
peut refaire de l'élevage bovin on peut
refaire de l'élevage ovin on peut on
peut faire mille et une choses mais
après c'est une question de choix donc
vers dans quelle direction voulons nous
aller justement parle des grilles
bashing les agriculteurs ont marre de se
sentir un peu stigmatiser finalement par
certains habitants certains militants
comment on fait pour recréer un peu ce
lien entre l'agriculteur et le
consommateur
alors il ya beaucoup plus agriculture en
province que dans les grosses villes
donc on reste sur des petites bourgades
avec des maires qui sont souvent issus
du monde agricole
je pense que ce lien avec le maire il
faut il faut le conserver il faut
discuter avec avec le maire et puis il
faut que le maire il informe la
population
il ya déjà des choses qui à mon avis ne
doivent plus être fait et il ya des
choses qui doit être diminué
progressivement il faut se donner les
moyens aussi aux agriculteurs de changer
et d'expliquer ce qu'ils font mais c'est
vrai que si on se met de la part du
citoyen on a acheté une petite maison en
bordure d'un champ on voit un gars
arriver qu'un gros tracteur qui traite
qui balancent des produits chimiques ça
sent mauvais on sait pas ce que c'est
est ce que c'est un produit complètement
naturel est ce que c'est un produit 100%
chimiques
aujourd'hui les produits phyto ils sont
tellement léger que dès qu'il ya du vent
ils peuvent être déplacés à des
kilomètres donc en fait quand on dit on
va faire une barrière de 5 ou 10 mètres
c'est totalement ridicule donc c'est
très bien ça c'est un truc est sorti
comme ça un peu du chapeau dernier
moment je crois qu'il faut plus de
concertation les agriculteurs sont les
premiers à vouloir expliquer leur métier
surtout les agriculteurs qui ont des
petites structures ils seront près de
leurs terres ils vivent dedans ils ont
peu envie d'avoir des cancers ils ont
pas envie en général que la nature soit
maltraité
on change de thématiques l'été est
particulièrement ensoleillé et sec ce
qui arrange les touristes en vacances
mais pas les agriculteurs au chant
le préfet des yvelines avait placé le
département en alerte sécheresse en
juillet dernier les restrictions avaient
été allégé le 21 août pour être prise le
11 septembre
ce mercredi le niveau a été baissé au
seuil de vigilance comment s'adapter à
ces états de sécheresse qui reviennent
de façon récurrente aujourd'hui alors là
c'est un véritable changement c'est un
bouleversement qu'il faut entreprendre
pour ma part sur la ferme de la petite
robe nous avons replanté au fur et à
mesure des années évidemment sur 30 ans
150 mille arbres pour créer un paysage
bocager il ya des aides aujourd'hui le
parc naturel régional de chevreuse aide
à replanter les arbres
on a des aides réel il faut absolument
recrée des est pourquoi parce que là
elle permet de fixer le lot
elle permet de donner de l'ombre elle
coupe le vent parce que quand il fait
chaud et qu'en plus il ya du vent ça
dessèche tout il faut refaire plus de
prairies on a besoin de prairies on
apporte notre miel alors autant avoir
des prairies mellifères qui vont
permettre de faire du miel on parle de
du méthane dégagé par par les vaches
oui quand elles sont élevées en pilote
c'est quand elles sont des milliers dans
des parcs à qui on file de l'ensilage de
maïs du tourteau de soja ogm
enfin tout un tas de saloperies qu'elle
devrait pas manger puisque une vache cet
herbivore à la base donc il faudrait
leur donner de l'herbe et du foin donc
quand elles sont nourries de façon
naturelle elles sont peu nombreuses
elles ont pas de choses qui fermente
dans l'eure dans leur ventre et elles
ont beaucoup moins de quasi pas de
dégagement de méthane au contraire ça
devient des puits de carbone et non pas
des émetteurs de carbone
rex en soit vous restez avec nous mardi
avait lieu une autre manifestation dans
plusieurs grandes villes de france les
retraités à l'appel de l'intersyndicale
de neuf organisations différentes ils se
sont mobilisés
principale revendication une
revalorisation des pensions avec
notamment une ré indexation sur
l'inflation et la suppression de la
contribution sociale généralisée csg
dans les yvelines la cgt a répondu
présentes des bus sont partis de poissy
et mantes la jolie direction paris les
autres ont emprunté le transilien nous
étions avec l'union locale de trappe
avant le départ d'abord il ya plusieurs
raisons la première raison c'est la
baisse du pouvoir d'achat depuis cinq
ans les retraités n'ont pas été
augmentés quasiment pas augmenté le
deuxième point c'est que les retraités
revendiquent également la gratuité des
transports vous qu'on considère que dans
le chaos n'est en activité 50% il pris
en charge
mais l'essentiel des problèmes des
retraités c'est la baisse du pouvoir
d'achat et sur les 240 mille retraités
qui est dans les yvelines
je peux vous assurer qu'il ya au moins
30 % de personnes qui sont en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté dont les agriculteurs
à la retraite aujourd'hui bénéficient
d'un régime spécial avec une retraite de
base de la mutuelle sociale agricole et
un complément auprès du régime agirc
qu avec un système de points aujourd'hui
ils touchent en moyenne 750 757 euros
par mois c'est une retraite qui est
difficile pour les possibles 750 euros
par mois pour vivre aujourd'hui c'est
impossible
je crois que la retraite d'un
agriculteur consolidé aux alentours de
900 euros
ça c'est pour l'agriculteur puisqu'en
général il est marié sa femme ne touche
rien donc ils vont être deux à vivre là
dessus non c'est tout à fait c'est tout
à fait impossible puisqu'on peut pas
parler de feignant un agriculteur ibos
12 14 heures par jour non non il faut il
faut c'est un si vous voulez le
l'agriculture ça doit bénéficier d'un
système spécifique comme comme il peut y
avoir chez certains fonctionnaires qui
ont qui ont des aides et puis souvent
ils ont commencé en étant aides
familiales donc il ne cotisait pas après
pour faire un complément de retraite les
agriculteurs vendent leurs structures
leurs enfants ils vont de ça évidemment
le plus cher possible parce que sinon
ils n'ont pas de qui peuvent pas vivre
la fin de leur vie donc les gamins ils
commencent avec un poids sur le dos
financier qui est énorme
et puis comme ça arrive souvent ce qu'on
a quand même beaucoup de décès d'un gris
culture ans n'est pas la profession de
gens qui ville la plus vieille loin de
là si jamais ils meurent avant d'avoir
pu céder leur leur fond de commerce
c'est à dire qu'il ya directement à un
système de succession avec des bâtiments
qui sont qui sont qui sont survalorisées
les gamins ils peuvent pas payer des
droits de succession ils ont six mois
pour les payer
ils peuvent pas vendre et voilà les
agriculteurs disparaissent au fur et à
mesure au profit d'une agriculture
industrielle dans lequel personne va
être gagnant sauf quelques très très
grosses familles ou groupes industriels
donc non la grille la halle à la
retraite des agriculteurs c'est une
misère merci ericsson est revenue sur
notre plateau je le rappelle vous êtes
éleveurs à auffargis à la ferme de la
petite guerre merci no reason ont fait
un saut dans le temps pour revenir sur
une autre manifestation le week-end
dernier 74 mille cinq cents personnes
selon un organisme de comptage
indépendant 66 cents mille selon les
organisateurs se sont réunies à paris
contre le projet de loi ouvrant la pma à
toutes les femmes à l'origine de cette
contestation un collectif la manif pour
tous qui déjà en 2013 s'opposer à la loi
ouvrant le mât
pour tous c'est votre rubrique ça s'est
passé
[Musique]
leur arme la rue les manifestants contre
le mariage pour tous l'ont envahie en
nombre samedi dernier date de l'adoption
par l'assemblée nationale du premier
article de la loi incriminée quinze
mille manifestants selon la police 22
mille selon les organisateurs
le rassemblement à versailles était
d'ailleurs le plus important au niveau
national parmi eux des responsables des
différentes communautés religieuses car
leur croyance ne serait pas compatible
avec le mariage pour tous ici pour nous
on va dire il ya deux types dorval a
alors venez qui émane de la tragédie
humaine hélas perdu son père il a perdu
sa mère il y en a qui le nouvel emplâtre
que l'institution française va pondre
aujourd'hui c'est la discussion violente
de la constitution à savoir que
l'entente va demain chercher son père ou
sa mère selon l'état va pas de trouver
ou delà du mariage homosexuel c'est donc
surtout la question de l'enfant qui
mobilise les communautés musulmane
catholique et protestante refuse le
droit à l'adoption par les couples
homosexuels et craignent d'éventuelles
dévoue je suis là parce qu'on sait très
bien de cette loi une fois qu'elle sera
votée et bien ouvrira la voie à la
procréation médicalement assistée pour
les femmes
logiquement par égalité des droits les
hommes demanderont la gestation pour
autrui et là dans les deux cas on est
dans l'adoption qui n'est pas une vraie
adoption et on est dans la
marchandisation du corps humain
la circulaire de madame taubira est la
preuve par neuf
malgré tous ces mensonges que la queue
lâché pea et est au programme
c'est évident le gouvernement a
cependant rappelé la semaine dernière
que la gestation pour autrui n'était pas
à l'agenda du quinquennat que convaincu
8000 croyants et laïque ont signé en
marge du rassemblement une pétition
nationale lancé par le maire divers
droite du chéné fils brio si le nombre
de 500 mille signataires est atteint le
conseil économique social et
environnemental devra étudier la
recevabilité de la loire
[Musique]
au vélodrome nationale la vitesse ne
sera plus seulement sur la piste le site
sportif vient d'être retenu par le
gouvernement comme lieu expérimental de
la 5g dix autres projets à travers la
france vont être équipés pour tester un
débit ultra rapide
les explications de mélanie poké et
patrick jacques de dixmude au vélodrome
nationale les épreuves sportives
pourrait se vivre différemment le site
saint quentinois va expérimenter la 5g
c'est pour le vélodrome et c'est ce
n'est pas dédié exclusivement puisqu'il
ya déjà des entreprises qui ont des
projets adjacent autour du vélodrome qui
vont pouvoir tester par exemple des
éléments de sécurité
je pense airbus je pense à d'autres
entreprises l agglomération à porter une
candidature en partenariat avec airbus
nokia france télévisions et qualcomm une
société américaine de technologies
mobiles
on pourrait avoir en temps direct
sur son téléphone des exemples à
l'avatar des l'avatar des cyclistes avec
leurs noms leurs caractéristiques tout
lors toutes leurs données instantanées
qui soit sur son téléphone en même temps
que le téléspectateur pourrez regarder
la course 1 débits multipliés par dix un
temps de latence divisé par dix son site
français ont été sélectionnés suite à
l'appel de l'arcep le régulateur des
télécoms français pour le moment on n'a
pas testé et donc il faut tout
construire il faut construire à la fois
des techno mais il faut construire aussi
les modèles d'affaires qu'on s'assure et
qui économiquement les intuitions sont
justes et pour faire ça il faut un bac à
sable qu'ils soient protégés ouvert où
tout le monde peut avoir accès et qui
permettent de tester pendant trois ans
les projets expérimenteront la bande de
fréquence 26 giga hertz une première en
france en point de mire pour le
vélodrome les jo de 2024 de la
technologie toujours avec le 3e salon
autonomie qui s'est tenue mercredi et
jeudi au campus des mureaux l'événement
est dédié à l'innovation pour
l'autonomie des personnes âgées et
handicapées
plus de 100 exposants étaient présents
sur place tard top association organisme
de formation pour proposer de nouvelles
solutions sur l'autonomie une vingtaine
d'ateliers de conférences animées par
des experts étaient également au
programme les propos recueillis sur
place par mme anne varaldo et patrick
jacques de dixmude autonomie a été créée
d'abord on a créé une vie
une vie c'est gérer un peu le centre
entre les entreprises les structures de
formation les patients tels et les
futurs employés et à partir de là partir
d'une vie on a réfléchi complètement sur
tout problème du grand âge et tout
problème de l'autonomie et à un moment
donné on sait nous sommes dit pourquoi
il ya trois ans n'ouvriront pas un salon
donne l'autonomie et notamment avec
comment le numérique ou être utile pour
les notions de dépendance et de grands
page vous pouvez retrouver vous pouvez
retrouver une édition spéciale du 7-8
société dédiée à l'autonomie des
personnes âgées et à mobilité réduite
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile le 26e festival de la
bande dessinée de buxy ce week end
tout autour différents ateliers ont été
organisés parmi eux une création de bd
avec des personnes condamnées et suivies
par la justice ce et erroc l'auteur des
profs qui a dirigé cette opération
reportage de référence la bonne ambiance
est au rendez vous pour cet atelier de
bande dessinée un peu particulier les
cinq participants sont des personnes
condamnées et suivi par le service
pénitentiaire d'insertion et de
probation des yvelines
cette opération a lieu dans le cadre de
la 26e édition du festival de rue est
consacrée au neuvième art but c'est
vraiment voilà de travailler ensemble de
découvrir une activité qu'on connaît pas
forcément et puis de pouvoir se dépasser
on s'y attend la confiance en soi le
dépassement de je connais pas mais je
peux y arriver
les participants ont eu deux jours pour
imaginer une bande dessinée comme
l'année dernière c'est le dessinateur et
rock à qui l'on doit notamment la série
les profs qui a conduit cet atelier ça
lieu qu'on connaît pas c'est une type de
public qu'on ne connaît pas non plus
parce qu'une entrée interventions
scolaires on va dans les écoles les
médiathèques là c'est intéressant déjà
travail des adultes ce que j'avais
jamais fait mois avant l'année dernière
ce que je trouve très sec chacun
s'entraide chaque participant donne un
coup de main sur le dessin de l'autre
pour ce petit groupe placés sous main de
justice cette activité a lieu dans le
cadre d'un module de réinsertion je
dessine énormément oui j'adore le dessin
donc tout ce qu'est activités manuelles
aussi donc j'adore ça elle prend son
temps pour nous expliquer les bases les
conseils comment on peut faire experts
j'ai eu un prophète était excellent
franchement j'ai passé en agréablement
m'avait des conseils pour le font pour
faire plus de rôles hier pour faire plus
de la distance
toutes les oeuvres vont être réunies et
seront exposés lors de la 26e édition du
festival de la bd à buc un peu de sport
maintenant avec la marche nordique notre
journaliste mélanie poquet s'y est
essayée juste avant l'édition de la
nordique royal reportage vous le
regardez c'est un sport venu tout droit
des pays nordiques pas besoin de
beaucoup de matériel pour le pratiquer
juste des bâtons
la marche nordique allons la découvrir
bonjour armen beau jeu mais l'année
quels sont les bienfaits de ce sport et
bien c'est une marche dynamique qui se
pratique dans la nature le plus souvent
dans les parcs et forêts environnantes
ici à versailles qui a besoin d'un grand
niveau s'est adapté à tout le monde
s'est adapté à tout le monde
faut être en forme et à quelques petites
contradictions si on a des problèmes de
tendinite mais sinon c'est ouvert à tout
le monde mais bon on peut le découvrir
bien sûr j'imagine on voit les
participants on commence par un
échauffement c'est ça bien sûr alors
c'est parti
[Musique]
ça fait changement et ça réveille
c'est en fait très agréable parce qu'on
sent que tout se réchauffe petit à petit
tu t'en devant la marche
un échauffement nécessaire de tout le
corps la marche nordique sollicite
jusqu'à 90% de nos muscles
armen nous voilà bien les chauffer on va
partir sur la marche mais on a des
bâtons j'imagine qu'il manière spéciale
de s'en servir
oui tout à fait le bâton ce nous fera
nous coupe il fait donc pour ça c'est
important de lancer son bras vers
l'avant le braille plutôt temps du
passage des hanches et ensuite on va
planter le bâton derrière et on a
toujours un bras une jambe opposée et le
bâton se plante derrière l'a fait
d'accord
sport très conviviale la marche nordique
se pratique idéalement en groupe grâce
au bâton en carbone un marcheur peut
atteindre 6 km heure très vite la marche
devient mature elle alors si vous aussi
vous voulez essayer il séances
d'initiation est prévue le dimanche 13
octobre à 10h30 et ça commence dès l'âge
de 16 ou 17 ans
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivi on se quitte sur des
emails d'un soigneur animalier dont le
portrait est à retrouver sur notre site
internet
week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]